you put me in a room with them I'm
coming out alive
so what about when I went whatever what
about when you use them on the street
and they're you know
you know I am possible I protect the bag
not leaving the house what would you
what would you do if you oh actually
question what would you do if you were
on the street and you saw your girl like
she said hi to him and didn't pretend
you didn't existed with that rubbing is
done there's there's many other 22s out
there
I thought you were the one I thought you
were the one yeah we're bringing in the
what if scenario so yeah so then she's
gone if she if she still talks but but
if you're say you're the one and she's
been Alpha widowed and that she
approaches to do the alpha wood with her
no but now you're bringing the analogy
of her getting off with it what could
never happen to me but I'm saying if we
if for this purpose of the scenario it
did then yeah it's done in it yeah
because it means it's still an opening
so an alpha Widow okay
I don't have the definition pulled up
but an alpha Widow basically is like
if a girl's a five or a six right most
people are average so most girls five
let's say five she sleeps with a guy
that's an eight
she falls in love with this man that's
why you always hear like girls in
situationships like they seem to be more
common than relationships these days and
the reason is it's because a small
percentage of men are sleeping with all
the girls and so the girl is so in love
with that guy that no other guy can
compare so it doesn't matter who she
dates after they can't beat that guy
that's why roller tomasi says and you're
kind of right with what you were saying
it's not about the number it's about the
number of Alphas so if like a girl's
only slept with five dudes but one of
them is Michael B Jordan like it's
cooked she's done she's done she's done
for her and like same with same with
Sierra like maybe you know maybe she
only slept with five but they're all
rappers future like what are you gonna
beat future oh like and so it's
basically like oh some guys say it's
some some people say it's or the girl
views that as the best she could do like
she can never do better and so then when
she starts aging out of the dating
Market when the attention's starting to
go she looks around and grabs the first
guy she can that's willing to marry her
and then she looks at him as less and
doesn't respect him
because she thinks oh I could have done
better I should be with that guy
hmm okay have you seen that dynamic
no never no okay sorry you've never had
a girl that's like afraid like that
can't get over her ex oh no yeah
absolutely so in a way that that's an
alpha Widow oh an alpha Widow like the
girl that that is always talking about
that one guy acts she hates him
like that that's definitely an outfit
we're doing for me exactly yeah
I love so it's such a complex thing to
boil down to he's an alpha
I mean okay the alpha the alpha term I
don't love and it's funny before I was
in this space I I sort of hated that
term too
because it's just like it it who's Alpha
right but it doesn't matter it's the
most Alpha guy that she can get
so it's the best that she can do it may
not be that he's the guy that walks in
terms of strengths intellect Financial
like many different things men bring
different things to the table and you
could I could date a really really
strong
the man that's in a gang and I know he
could protect me or I could date a man
that's really really really rich or I
could date a man that has a very high
intellect like so so it goes contextual
yeah yeah and so it goes down to money
muscles game and frame what is so so
frame is basically you're entering his
frame and he's not entering yours so
frame it in a way is masculinity
I don't still understand
um okay so if you work for somebody
it's oh you're stepping into them yes
yes versus him stepping so it's like
leadership
like holding frame is when you when you
like make fun of it so away girls will
do a [__] test is what they call it is
they'll make fun of a guy a little bit
and you want you don't know this
consciously but you're watching to see
how he reacts does he make fun of you
back does he kind of like play into it
or does he does he like get offended and
if he gets offended that's him falling
into your frame because he's this yeah
yeah because he's thinking but we had to
do this historically because we had to
make sure the guy could protect us okay
yeah and so that's why if a guy kind of
makes fun of you like comes up to you
and is like what's wrong with that
you're like like you're kind of more
interested right but it's it's him
because you're going into his frame okay
and so and it's what the girl values so
like I I was really involved in a church
when I lived in Milwaukee and all the
girls there it was relationship with God
so they wanted like that was the most
Alpha guy they could get had the closest
relationship with God it was kind of
that's what I was thinking of when you
were talking about the different
communities was the guys there that got
all the girls probably would be viewed
as beta in the normal world but they but
they were getting the virgins
ideal right it's not it's not like
that's not funny I think I think just to
add to your point right perception is
everything from the woman's standpoint
if she perceives the man as an alpha
then that's all that really matters it
doesn't matter if her friends don't see
him yeah it's all about her so she would
be Alpha widowed by that man because she
perceived him as an author yeah and that
the point comes down to women actually
want men women actually want men better
than them that doesn't necessarily mean
that the man is better than them but she
wants to see him as better than her yeah
I get that yeah and so that's the
problem with girls with a bad boy past
is because oftentimes she doesn't she
wants that guy because hey he didn't
love her very close but aren't these 20
that are getting all the women bad boys
no not at all I wouldn't say all some
some are I mean some of the bases are in
the 20 or is it maybe like the Alphas
and they're getting all the women and
then the women are ruined and then
they're like oh we're gonna go to the
other 80 sort of I mean to be an alpha
doesn't mean that you're a bad boy like
someone like for example let's say
[__] I don't know Joe Biden yeah I'd
say my older brother's in Alpha but he's
a really geeky yeah
we have loads of women would understand
throw themselves at him yeah it's just
basically that women women
I think they'd kill him if they feed
himself smash your path show about it
in the dirt
someone on Twitter the other day was
like oh my gosh Joe Biden is such a good
looking man I would go to him and I
would move to him and someone was like
yeah I want my students load and paid
off too but that's not the way to do it
girl yeah but big thing about this way
because those you don't value money in
the same way but if you show Joe Biden
to like loads of girls from Venezuela
who are from the slums you'll be like
yeah I'm wondering yeah but that
wouldn't be
because I honestly I think everything
starts with looks because I I think that
if you want a girl to genuinely desire
you like you have to be somewhat similar
on the looks level yeah because if if a
dude is like okay if you if you
multi-millionaire tomorrow right or
let's say let's say fat guy right
multi-millionaire tomorrow he can get a
girl it's an eight nine or ten but she's
just with him for the money so it's not
like that genuine desire like like a lot
of Attraction is chemical so so women
can women can smell a T-shirt and see
which guy they'd be the most attracted
to so it's you know it's not it's not
that genuine desire I don't know you say
that but it all depends on
where skewed in terms of your brain of
thinking what you find of attractive
like is the stat is the most attractive
thing to you is